the mainstream media shops like the new
york times washington post and the
broadcast networks
stand accused of gaslighting the
american people that's distracting us
from what really ails the country
msnbc's chuck todd is one of those
trying to change the subject
making the outrageous claim that liberal
bias
does not exist where we did get lost in
this and this sort of happened to
to mainstream media in particular is
that
we did let republican critics get in our
heads
the republicans have been running on
there's a liberal bias in the media we
shouldn't accepted the premise that
there was liberal bias
katie how can he with a straight face
claim that there isn't liberal bias
because he's in a bubble
a liberal bubble so he can't see
or look in the mirror and see everything
that's happened i mean seven percent
of reporters across the entire country
identify as republicans
i've never seen a right-leaning comedian
be invited to the white house
press corps dinner the correspondents
association dinner dana has a lot of
experience with
liberal media bias defending a
republican president and if you look at
the percentages of positive coverage for
republican presidents first positive
coverage for democratic presidents
and just the type of questions that are
asked let's not forget that the media
said that
barack obama had no scandals at the end
of his administration when there were
plenty of scandals
the list goes on and on but it's a chuck
todd's comments are a perfect reflection
of
liberal media living in a liberal media
bubble but then wait a minute
any self-reflection where do you go for
your news right here well
foxnews and townhall.com that's it
what about the new york times you just
told me you don't trust the new york
times
and i trust you geraldo thank you i
trust you too so what do you do jesse
how do you you're a consumer of news
you hear chuck todd saying there's no
liberal bias give me a
quantity percentage of liberal
to conservative bias biases
well unscientifically i'd say 95 to 95
yeah i think about that's right
unscientifically i think he's going
through a midlife
crisis chuck chuck something i'm
familiar with
he came over yours is over
thankfully he's remember tim russert had
meet the press for 4 million
great guys watching on sunday great guy
right first place
now chuck has it barely 2 million in
third place
and his show on msnbc barely
gets 700 000 people okay they had to
bump it because it was so poorly rated
it is ranked
30th 30th geraldo he is losing to people
i've never heard of he's losing to a guy
on msnbc named
ayman mohuyelden i'm in mohawk yeldon is
beating chuck todd
the political director is that a puerto
rican name i don't even know what it is
geraldo but he's losing to a guy i've
never heard of so
chuck todd is struggling to understand
in his midlife crisis
why people don't like him and like most
liberals he's blaming other people
you don't like him because you don't
trust him because he was wrong on donald
trump in 2016.
wrong on russia wrong on the border
wrong in the laptop
wrong on the lab leak so when chuck todd
says there's no liberal media bias
that's how i know he's biased
if you just admit he was biased we could
play it straight isn't dana isn't that
the wuhan live isn't that
that's even more glaring than the
collusion the russia
i think also the the how the media
locked arms to protect hunter biden from
good ones goodwill coverage but i also
think that these voting rights bills
uh that are happening all across the
country there's a really interesting
test that you can do to see
um so there's one broadcast network i
watch every single night
really like the product but i've got to
say i think they're pretty straight
usually
on the voting issue it's been
unbelievably bad
terribly bad so yeah i know i'm guessing
abc
they first of all they almost never
quote
a single republican or conservative ever
they also
um basically never mention anything that
people that are maybe voting against
these bills would be opposed to like
they don't they don't even mention it
for example
hr one would have ended voter id they
don't
it's like they don't even they don't
mention it um they use all the left's
terms
like restrictions rather than any
well reform yeah it's restrictions it's
suppression usually that's the other
word i was looking for
and they never cite their sources right
so they don't say well this came from
the brennan center well who funds the
brennan center
um yeah but your favorite
but in terms of uh you have to get the
news from someplace
yeah you can't just only watch one
network all day long
what do you do you have to read a
newspaper i think you watch the stuff
that is correctly labeled
like fox news you know what's news you
know what's commentary you know what the
five is the problem with msnbc
maybe it's time to chuck todd oh uh and
the reason why we get in their heads by
the way
is because there's lots of room but they
don't they don't like the people on cnn
and the people on msnbc they don't label
themselves
when they're commentating now if he said
that i mean he's supposed to be a news
guy right yeah
but he says the things that are clearly
an opinion don't you think they believe
what they are saying i think they're
probably in denial it's all you know
it's
it's weird it's kind of like i kind of
enjoy this because the facts
dispute everything he says you know and
and uh and i think he just
it's like when people say you're racist
and you go uh no i'm not and they go
that's proof you're racist that's
exactly what's happening here it says
i'm not biased well that's kind of
evidence you are biased
yeah that's what it is they they they're
they are delusional and they're in
denial
i don't know what the next step is i am
biased yes you are and me too
the fact hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else